Je crois que c'est l'avenir des médias.
La majorité des stratégies médiatiques et de changement social
ont tenté de plaire à de larges publics
mais le futur, ce sont des médias personnalisés pour chacun.
La mesure en temps réel de la consommation médiatique
et la production médiatique automatisée deviennent la norme,
nous consommerons bientôt des médias directement adaptés à nos besoins
en utilisant un mélange de psychographie, de biométrie et d'IA.
C'est comme de la médecine personnalisée se reposant sur notre ADN.
J'appelle cela la « biomédiatique ».
Je teste actuellement le Labo limbique dans une étude pilote
avec le centre Norman Lear
étudiant le top 50 des séries télévisées.
Mais je fais face à un dilemme éthique.
Si je conçois un outil pouvant être transformé en arme,
devrais-je le créer ?
En rendant le labo open source
pour encourager l'accessibilité et l'inclusivité,
je prends aussi le risque de permettre à des gouvernements puissants
et des entreprises à but lucratif de s'approprier la plateforme
pour de l'infox, du marketing et d'autres formes de persuasion de masse.
Par conséquent, pour moi, il est crucial de rendre ma recherche
aussi transparente aux gens ordinaires que les labels pour les OGM.
Cependant, cela ne suffit pas.
En tant que technologues créatifs,
nous avons la responsabilité
de non seulement réfléchir à comment les technologies actuelles
façonnent nos valeurs culturelles et notre comportement social,
mais aussi d'activement remettre en cause la trajectoire des technologies futures.
J'espère que nous nous engagerons
à exploiter l'intelligence du corps
pour la création d'histoires authentiques et justes
qui font passer les médias et les technologies
d'armes néfastes à un remède narratif.
Merci.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)